okay so great to see everyone back for
lecture four of the class so for lect
for today's lecture what I want to do
for most of the time is actually get
into the heart of these ideas of having
the back propagation algorithm for
neural nets and how we can construct
computation graphs that allow us
efficiently to do back propagation your
nets to train the neural Nets so overall
this is sort of what I plan to do it
today so at the end of last lecture I
slightly ran out of time and I started
mumbling and waving my hands about the
doing the derivatives with respect to
the weight gradient so I kind of wanted
to do that bit again so hopefully it
actually communicates slightly better so
we'll do that and talk a bit more about
sort of just tips for doing matrix
gradients and a particular issue that
comes up with word vectors and so then
the main part of the class will be
talking about the back propagation
algorithm and how it runs over
computation graphs and then for the last
part of the class is I'm not going to
hide it
this is sort of just a grab bag of
miscellaneous stuff you should know
about neural networks and training
neural networks like I think you know we
dream of a future of artificial
intelligence where our machines are
really intelligent and you can just say
to them this is the data and this is my
problem go and train me a model and it
might work and in some future world that
maybe what comes along it's something
that's certainly being actively
researched at the moment under the topic
of auto ml I guess the question is
whether it turns out that auto ml is a
scalable solution or the climate change
consequences of auto ml techniques are
sufficiently bad that someone actually
decides that these much lower power
neural systems might actually be better
still for doing some parts of the
problem but
either way we're not really there yet
and the fact of the matter is when
you're training neural networks there's
just a whole bunch of stuff you have to
know about initialization and
nonlinearities and learning rates and so
on and you know well I taught this class
last time I somehow thought that people
would pick this up by osmosis that if we
get gave starter cut code to people and
in our starter code we initialized how
matrices and we set our learning rates
that by osmosis people would understand
that's what you have to do and do it and
didn't really sort of teach in class the
practical tips and tricks enough but it
was perfectly obvious that when we got
to final project time there at least for
quite a few people osmosis hadn't worked
so this time I'm at least willing to
spend a few minutes on that and at least
point out some of the things that are
important and I mean just in general you
know the reality of 2018 deep learning
paths now wait 2019 now 2019 deep
learning is deep learning is still kind
of a craft there's quite a bit you have
to know of techniques of doing things
that lead neural net training to work
successfully as opposed to your models
failing to work successfully okay one
final announcement and I go in through
it so we've sort of been doing some
further working on office our placement
and I guess there are sort of multiple
issues which include opportunities for
local SCPD students without Stanford IDs
we have to get to office hours so for
the Thursday night office hour
that's after this class if you'd like to
go and talk about the second homework
the Thursday night office hour is going
to be in thought at Thornton 110 now I
didn't know where Thornton was it made
more sense to me when I translated that
as that's the old Terman annex but
that's probably just showing my age
since probably none of you remember when
there used to be a building called
Thurmond so that probably doesn't help
you either but you know if you're
heading I don't know which direction
we're facing if you're heading that way
I guess and if you know where the pop
your new guinea sculpture garden is the
the sort of open grassy area before you
get to the Papua New Guinea sculpture
garden
that's where Turman used to be and the
building that still stands in there is
thornton thornton 110 tonight i think it
starts at 6:30 right 639 okay right so
let me just finish off where we were
last time so remember we had this window
of five words and then we were putting
it through a new net layer of Z equals W
X plus B non-linearity of H equals f of
X and then we are going to just get a
score as to whether this has in its
centre named entity like Paris which is
sort of taking this dot product of a
vector times the hidden layer so this
was our model and then we were wanting
to work out partial derivatives of s
with respect to all of our variables and
we did various of the cases but one we
handy had done is the weights and the
weights or all of this neural net layer
here
okay so chain rule the partial of the
SDW of is the s times h d the h DZ times
DZ d w and well if you remember last
time we'd sort of done some computation
of what those first two partial
derivatives were and we said that we
could just call those delta which is our
error signal coming from above and that
concept of having an error signal coming
from above is something I'll get back to
in the main part of the lecture and a
sort of a central notion but the bit we
haven't dealt with is this DZ DW and we
started to look at it and I made the
argument based on our shape convention
that the shape of that should be the
same shape as our W matrix so it should
be the same in time
in shape as this w matrix so we want to
work out the partial of Z by W which is
the same as this ZW x + B DW and so we
want to work out what that derivative is
and if that's not obvious one way to
think about it is to go back to this
elements of the matrix and actually
first off work it out element wise and
think out what it should be and then
once you've thought out what it should
be to rewrite it back in matrix form to
give the compact answer so what we have
is we have these inputs here and a bias
term and we're going to do the matrix
multiply of this vector to produce these
and if you think about what's happening
there so we've got this matrix of
weights and for a particular weight a
weight is first index is going to
correspond to a position in the hidden
layer and it's second index is going to
correspond to a position in the input
vector and one ways in the matrix ends
up being part of what's used to compute
one element of the hidden layer so the
one element of the hidden layer you're
taking a row of the matrix and you're
multiplying it by the components of this
vector so they sum together and the bias
is added on but one element of the
matrix is sort of only being used in a
computation between one element of the
important one element of the hidden
vector okay so well that means if we're
thinking about what's the partial
derivative with respect to W IJ
well it's only contributing to Zi and
it's only it's only doing anything with
XJ so that we end up with when we're
getting the partial with respect to W IJ
we can work that out with respect to
just respect Zi and when we're going to
look at this multiplication here what
we're ending up is this sort of
of terms wik times XK where there's sort
of weights in that row of the matrix
going across the positions of the vector
so the only position in which W IJ is
used is multiplying by XJ and at that
point what we have in terms of sort of
you know basic one variable doing a
differentiation this is just like we
have three X and we say what's the
derivative of 3x max just X is confusing
sorry I shouldn't say that it's like we
have three W and what's the derivative
of three W with respect to W it's three
right so that we've have a term here
which is will have been W will be W IJ
times XJ and its derivative with respect
to W IJ is just XJ that makes sense if
you want to leave it fingers crossed
okay so so for one element of this
matrix we're just getting out XJ and at
that point we say well of course we want
to know what the Jacobian is for the
full matrix W well if you start thinking
about it this argument applies to every
cell so that for every cell of the
Jacobian for W it's going to be XJ so
that means we're just going to be able
to make use of that in calculating our
Jacobian so the derivative for a single
W IJ is Delta I XJ and that's true for
all cells so we want to have a matrix
for our Jacobian which has Delta I XJ in
every cell Evert and the way we can
create that is by using an outer product
so if we have a row vector of the deltas
the error signals from above and a
column wait I say that wrong sorry if we
have a column of the Delta arrow signals
from above
we have a row of X transpose vector when
we multiply those together we get the
outer product and we get Delta I XJ in
each cell and that is our to Co be an
answer for working out the Delta s Delta
W that we started off with at the
beginning okay and this and we get this
form where it's a multiplication of an
error signal from above and our computed
local gradient signal and that's the
pattern that we're going to see over and
over again and that will exploit in our
computation graphs okay all good okay
so here's just you know homework two
you're meant to do some of this stuff
here it s sort of a couple of collected
tips which I hope will help I mean
keeping here track of your variables and
their dimensionality is really useful
because if you just can work out what
the dimensionality of things should be
you're often kind of halfway there
I mean basically what you're doing is
sort of applying the chain rule over and
over again it always looks like this but
doing it in this sort of matrix calculus
sense of the chain rule in the homework
you have to do a softmax which we
haven't done in class something that I
think you'll find useful if you want to
break apart the softmax is to consider
two cases one the cases - when you're
working it out for the correct class and
then the other case is for all the other
incorrect classes yeah I'm in the in the
little derivation I did before I said
well let's work out an element-wise
partial derivative because that should
give me some sense of what's going on
what the answer is I think that can be a
really good thing to do if you're
getting confused by matrix calculus and
I sort of slightly skip past another
slide last time I was talking about the
shape convention that I talked about it
for a moment but for
or the homeworks you can work out your
answer however you want you can work it
out in terms of you know numerator
ordered jacobians if that seems best to
you but we'd like you to give the final
answer to your assignment questions
following the shape convention so that
the derivatives should be shaped in a
vector or matrix in the same way as the
variable with respect to which you're
working out your derivatives
okay the last little bit for finishing
up this example from last time I want to
say a little bit about is what happens
with words and one answer is nothing
different but another answer is they are
a little bit of a special case here
because you know really we have a matrix
of word vectors right we have a vector
for each word and so then you can think
of that as sort of this matrix of word
vectors which row as a different word
but we're not actually kind of
connecting up that matrix directly to
our classifier system instead of that
what we connect connecting up to the
classifier system is this window and the
window we'll have it in at five words
most commonly they're different words
but you know occasionally the same word
might appear in two positions in that
window and so we can nevertheless do
exactly the same thing and continue our
gradients down and say okay let's work
out the gradients of this word window
vector and if these are of dimension D
we'll have this sort of five D vector
but you know then what do we do about it
and the answer to what we do about it is
we can just sort of split this window
vector into five pieces and say aha
we have five updates to word vectors
we're just going to go off and apply
them to the words vector matrix and you
know if we if the same word occurs twice
in that window we literally apply both
of the updates so
it is it's updated twice or maybe
actually you want to sum them first and
then do the update once but yeah that's
a technical issue so so what that
actually means is that we're extremely
sparsely updating the word vector matrix
because most of the word vector matrix
will be unchanged and just a few rows of
it will be being updated and if soon
we're going to be you know doing stuff
with PI torch and if you poke around PI
torch even has some special stuff look
for things like sparse SGD for meaning
that you're sort of doing a very sparse
updating like that but there's one other
sort of interesting thing that you
should know about for a lot of things
that you do is just what actually
happens if we push down these gradients
into our word vectors well the idea is
you know if we do that would be just
like all other neural net learning that
we will sort of in principle say move
the word vectors around in such a way as
they're more useful in helping determine
named entity classification in this case
because that was our motivating example
so you know it might for example learn
that the word in is a very good
indicator of named into default I'm
sorry the place name following so after
in you often get London Paris etc right
so it's sort of got a special behavior
that other prepositions don't as being a
good location indicator and so it could
sort of move its location around and say
here are words that are good location
indicators and therefore help our
classifier work even better so on
principle that's good and it's a good
thing to do to update word vectors to
help you perform better on a supervised
tasks such as this named entity
recognition classification but there's a
catch which is that it doesn't always
work actually and so why doesn't it
always work well suppose that we're
training a classifier you know it could
be the
one I just did or a softmax or logistic
regression and we're wanting to classify
movie reviews sentiment for positive or
negative well you know if we have
trained our word vectors we've got some
word vector space and maybe in the word
vector space TV telly and television are
all very close together because they
mean basically the same thing so that's
great our word vectors are good but well
suppose it was the case that in our
training data for our classifier so this
is our training data for movie sentiment
review we had the word TV and telly but
we didn't have the word television well
then what's going to happen is well
while we try and train our sentiment
classifier if we push gradient back down
into the word vectors what's likely to
happen is that it will move around the
word vectors of the words we saw in the
training data but necessarily
televisions not moving right because
we're only pushing gradient down to
words or in our training data so this
word goes nowhere so it just stays where
it was all along so if the result of our
training is words get moved around so
here are good words for indicating
negative sentiment will actually if a
test time when we're running our model
if we evaluate on a sentence with
television in it it's actually going to
give the wrong answer whereas if we
haven't changed the word vectors at all
and it just left them where our word
embedding learning system put them then
it would have said television that's a
word that means about the same as TV or
tele I should treat it the same in my
sentiment classifier and it would
actually do a better job so it's sort of
two-sided whether you've gained by
training word vectors and so this is a
summary that says that it's two-sided
and practically what you should do so
the first choice is gee
it's a good idea to use pre-trained word
vectors like the word to vech vech ters
that used an assignment one or using the
training methods that you're doing right
now for homework two and the answer that
is almost always yes and the reason for
that is these word vector training
methods are extremely easy to run on
billions and words of text so we you
know train these models like glove or
word thick on billions or tens of
billions of words and it's easy to do
that for two reasons firstly because the
training algorithms are very simple
right that the word defect training
algorithm skip Graham's very simple
algorithm secondly because we don't need
any expensive resources all we need is a
big pile of text documents and we can
run it on them so really easy to run it
on you know five or fifty billion words
whereas you know we can't do that for
most of the classifiers that we want to
build because if it's something like a
sentiment classifier or a named Indy
recognizer we need label training data
to train our classifier and then we ask
someone or how many words of label
training data do you have for named
entity recognition and they give us back
a number like three hundred thousand
words or 1 million words right it's
orders of magnitude smaller ok so
therefore we can gain using pre trained
word vectors because they know about all
the words that aren't in our supervised
classifiers training data and they also
know much more about the words that
actually are in the training data but
only rarely so the exception to that is
if you have hundreds of millions of
words of data then you can start off
with random word vectors and go from
there and so a case where this is
actually commonly done is for machine
translation which we do later in the
class it's relatively easy for large
languages to get hundreds of millions of
words of translated text if you want to
build something like German English or
Chinese English machine translation
system not hard to get a hundred and
fifty million words of translated text
and so that's sort of sufficiently much
data that people commonly just
start with word vectors being randomly
initialized and start training their
translation system okay so in the second
question is okay I'm using pre trained
word vectors when I train my supervised
classifier should I push gradients down
into the word vectors and up and update
them which is often referred to as
fine-tuning the word vectors or should I
not should I just sort of throw away
those gradients and not push them down
into the word vectors and you know the
answer that is it depends and it just
depends on the size so if you only have
a small training data set
typically it's best to just treat the
pre trained word vectors as fixed and
not do any updating of them at all if
you have a large data set then you can
normally gain by doing fine-tuning of
the word vectors and of course the
answer here is what counts as large you
know if certainly if you're down in the
regime of a hundred thousand words a
couple hundred thousand words you're
small if your time to be over a million
words then maybe you're large but you
know and practice people do it both ways
and see which number is higher and
that's what they stick with ya then the
sort of there's the sort of point here
that's just worth underlining is yeah so
in principle we can back propagate this
gradient to every variable in our model
it's actually a theorem that we can
arbitrarily decide to throw any subset
of those gradients away and we're still
improving the log likelihood of our
model right it kind of can't be
inconsistent you can just so pick some
subset and say only train those 37 and
throw away all the rest and the
algorithm will still improve the log
likelihood of the model perhaps not by
as much as if you train the rest of the
variables as well but yeah it can't
actually do any harm not to train
anything that's one of the reasons why
often people don't notice bugs in their
code as well is
because if your code is kind of broken
and only half of the variables are being
updated it'll still seem to be training
something and improving it's just not
doing as well as it could be doing if
you'd code it correctly okay
so at this point that sort of almost
shown you back propagation right so back
propagation is really taking derivatives
with a generalized chain role with the
one further trick which we sort of
represented with that Delta which is G
you want to be clever in doing this so
you minimize computation by reusing
shared stuff but now what I want to move
on is to sort of look at how we can do
that much more systematically which is
this idea we have a computation graph
and we're going to run a back
propagation algorithm through the
computation graph so this is kind of
like an abstract syntax tree expression
tree that you might see in a compilers
class or something like that right so
when we have an arithmetic expression of
the kind that we're going to compute we
can make this tipped over on its side
tree representation so we've got the X
and W variables we're going to multiply
them there's the B variable we're going
to add it to the previous partial result
we're going to stick it through our
non-linearity F and then we're going to
multiply it by U and that was the
computation that we're doing in our
neural network so the source nodes are
inputs the interior nodes of this tree
are operations and then we've got these
edges that pass along the results of our
computation and so this is the
computation graph for precisely the
example I've been doing for the last
lecture and electron or Eilish okay so
there are two things that we want to be
able to do the first one is we want to
be able to start with these variables
and do this computation and calculate
what s is that's the part that's dead
simple that's referred to as forward
propagation so forward propagation is
just expression evaluation as you do
in any programming language interpreter
that's not hard at all but the
difference here is hey we want to do a
learning algorithm so we're going to do
the opposite of that as well
what we want to be able to do is also
backward propagation or back propagation
or just back prop it's commonly called
which is we want to be able to go from
the final part the final part here and
then at each step we want to be
calculating these partial derivatives
and passing them back through the graph
and so this was sort of the notion
before that we had an error signal right
so starting from up here we've
calculated a partial of s by Z which is
this with respect to that and so that's
sort of our calculated error signal up
to here and then we want to pass that
further back to start computing our
gradients further back right and we
started off right here with the partial
of s by s what's the partial of s but is
going to be one okay yes so the rate at
which s changes the rate at which s
changes so we just start off with one
and then we want to work out how this
gradient changes as we go along so what
we're doing here is when we're working
out things for one node that a node is
going to have passed into it it's
upstream gradient which is its error
signal so that's the partial of our
final final result which was our loss by
the variable that was the output of this
computation node so that's the partial
of s by H here and then we did some
operation here here's the non-linearity
but it might be something else and so
what we wanted then work out is a
downstream gradient which is the partial
of s by Z which was the input of this
function and well then the question is
how do we do that and the answer that is
we use the chain rule of course right so
at
we have a concept of a local gradient so
here's H is the output z is the input so
this function here and this is our
non-linearity right so this is whatever
we're using as our non-linearity like a
logistic or at an age we're calculating
H in terms of Z and we can work out the
partial of H by Z so that's our local
gradient and so then if we have both the
upstream gradient and the local gradient
we can then work out the downstream
gradient because we know the partial of
s by Z is going to be DSD a times D H DZ
and so then we'll be able to pass down
the downstream gradient to the next node
ok so our basic rule which is just the
chain rule written in different terms is
downstream gradient equals upstream
gradient times local gradient easy as
that ok so this was the very simplest
case where we have a node with one input
and one output so that's a function like
our logistic function but we also want
to have things work out for a general
computation graph so how are we going to
do that well the next case is what about
if we have multiple inputs so if we're
calculating something like Z equals W
times X we're actually yes Z and X of
themselves vectors and W is a matrix but
we're treating X as only important W as
an input and Z is our output right we
kind of group vectors and matrices
together well if you have multiple
inputs you then end up with multiple
local gradients so you can work out the
partial of Z with respect to X or the
partial of Z u with respect to W and so
you essentially you take the upstream
gradient you multiply it by each of the
local gradients and you pass it down the
respective path and we calculate these
differ
and downstream gradients to pass along
that making sense
yeah okay I'll chug
okay so let's sort of look at an example
of this and then we'll see one another
case so here's a little baby example
this isn't kind of really looking like a
neural net but we've got three imports x
y and z and x and y get added together
and y and z get maxed and then we take
the results of those two operations and
we multiply them together so overall
what we're calculating is X plus y times
the max of y plus C but you know we have
here a general technique and we can
apply it in any cases okay so if we want
to have this graph and we want to run it
forward well we need to know the values
of x y and z so for my example x equals
1 y equals to z equals 0 so we take the
values of those variables and push them
on to the calculations for the forward
arrows and then well the first thing we
do is add and the result of that is
three and so we can put that onto the
arrow that's the output of ad max it's 2
is the output of the value of air x is 6
and so the forward pass we have
evaluated the expression it's value is 6
that wasn't hard ok so then the next
step is we then want to run that
propagation to work out gradients and so
we sort of want to know how to sort of
work out these local gradients so a is
out right a is the result of some so
here's a as the result of some so a
equals x plus y so if you're taking da
DX that's just 1 and da dy is also 1
that makes sense
the max is slightly trickier because
where there's some slope some gradient
for the max depends on which one's
bigger so if y is bigger than Z D Delta
the partial of B by Z partial B by Y is
1 otherwise at 0 and conversely for the
partial of B by Z so now that one's a
little bit dependent and then we do the
multiplication case at the end and work
out its partials with respect to a and B
and since that's a B which has the
values 2 and 3 if you're taking the
partial of F by a it equals B which is 2
and vice versa okay so that means we can
work out the local gradients at each
node and so then we want to use those to
calculate our gradients backwards in the
back propagation path so we start at the
top the partial of F with respect to F
is 1 because if you move if you know by
1/10 then you've moved the F by 1/10 so
that's a Counsel's out as 1 okay so then
we want to pass backwards so the first
thing that we have is this sort of
multiply node and so we work we know
it's local gradients the partial of F by
a is 2 and the partial of F by B is 3
and so we get those values so formally
we're taking the local gradients
multiplying them by the upstream
gradients and getting our 3 and 2 and
notice the fact that sort of effectively
what happened is the values on the two
arcs swaps and then we sort of continue
back okay there's a max node so our
upstream gradient is now 3 and then we
want to multiply by the local gradient
and since the max of these two is 2
there's a slope of 1 on this side so we
get 3 there's no gradient on this side
and we get 0 and then we do the similar
calculation on the other side where we
have local gradients of 1
and so both of them come out of two and
then the one other thing to do is we
notice well wait a minute
there are two arcs that started from the
Y both of which we've back propagated
some gradient on and so what do we do
about that what we do about that is we
sum so the partial of F by X is 2 the
partial of F by Z is 0 but the partial
of F by Y is the sum of the two and five
right and so this isn't complete voodoo
this is something that should make sense
in terms of what gradients are right so
that what we're saying is what we're
calculating is if you wiggle X a little
bit how big an effect does that have on
the outcome of the whole thing and so
you know we should be able to work this
out so our X started off as one but
let's suppose we wiggle it up a bit to
make it one point one well according to
this our output should change by about
zero point two it should be magnified by
two and we should be able to work that
out right so it's then one point one
plus two so that's then three point one
and then we've got the two here that
multiplies by it and it's six point two
and lo and behold it went up by point to
right so that seems correct and if we
try and do the same for well let's do
the Z it's easy so if we wiggle the Z
which had a value of the zero by 0.1
this is zero point one when we max it if
this is still two and so a calculated
value doesn't change it's still six so
the gradient here is zero we doing this
does nothing and then the final one is y
so it's starting off value as two so if
we wiggle it a little and make a two
point one our claim is that the results
sort of change by about 0.5 it should be
multiplied by five times so if we make
this two point one we then have two
point one plus one would be three point
one
when we get the max here it also be 2.1
and so it have to point one times three
point one and that's to harder rithmetic
for me to do in my head that if we take
two point one times three point one it
comes out of six point five one so
basically it's gone up by half right if
we don't expect the answers to be exact
of course right because you know that's
not the way calculus works right well
I'm just that that it's showing that
we're getting the gradients right okay
so this actually works so what are the
techniques that we need to know so we've
sort of already seen them all so you
know we discussed when there are
multiple incoming arcs how he saw work
out the different local derivatives
their main other case that we need to
know is if in the function computation
there's a branch outward the result of
something is used in multiple places and
so this was like the case here I mean
here this was an initial variable but
you know it could have been computed by
something further back so if this thing
is used in multiple places and you have
the computation going out in different
ways it's just this simple rule that
when you do back propagation backwards
use some the gradients that you get from
the different outward branches okay so
if a equals x plus y and well that's one
we showed you before that we're doing
this sum operation to work out the total
partial of F by Y okay and if you sort
of think about it just a little bit more
there are sort of these obvious patterns
which we saw in this very simple example
so if you've got a plus that really the
upstream gradient is going to be sort of
heading down every one of these grant
branches when you have multiple branches
or things being summed now in this case
it just is copied unchanged but that's
because our comp
tation was x plus y you know it could be
more complicated but we're passing it
down down each of those branches so plus
distributes upstream gradient when you
have a max that's kind of like a
ralphing operation because max is going
to be sending the gradient to in the
direction that's the max and other
things are going to get no gradient
being passed down to them and then when
you have a multiplication this has this
kind of fun effect that what you do is
switch the gradient ride and so this
reflects the fact that when you have u
times V regardless of whether u and V
are vectors or just scalars that the
derivative of the result with respect to
u is V and the derivative of a spot
result with respect to V is U and so the
gradient signal is the flip of the two
numbers on the different sides okay so
this is sort of most of how we have
these computation graphs and we can work
out back propagation backwards in them
there's sort of one more part of this to
do which is to say gee we want to do
this efficiently so there's a bad way to
do this which is to say oh well we
wanted to calculate the partial vez by B
and so we can calculate that part roll
which was essentially what I was doing
on last time slides we say partial of F
by B equals the partial of s by H times
the partial of H by Z times the partial
of Z by B and we have all of those
partials we work them all out and
multiply them together and then someone
says what's the partial of s by W and we
say huh that's the chain rule again I'll
do it all again it's the partial of F by
H times the partial of H by Z times the
partial of Z by X no mo right lost it
but you do a big long list of them
and you calculate it all again that's
not what we want to do instead we want
to say I look there's this shared stuff
there's this error signal coming from
above and we can work out the error
signal the upstream gradient for this
node we can use it to calculate the
upstream gradient for this node we can
use this to calculate the upstream
gradient for this node and then using
the local gradients of which they're too
calculated this node we can then
calculate this one and that one and then
from here having knowing this upstream
gradient we can use the local gradients
at this node to compute this one and
that one and so we're sort of doing this
efficient computer science like
computation where we don't do any
repeated work that makes sense yeah okay
and so if that is the whole of backprop
so here's sort of a slightly sketchy
graph which is sort of just
recapitulating this thing so if you have
any computation that you want to perform
well the hope is that you can sort your
nodes into what's called a topological
sort which means the things that are
arguments variables that are arguments
are sorted before variables that are
results that depend on that argument you
know providing you have something
there's an acyclic graph you'll be able
to do that if you have a psychic graph
you're in trouble
well I mean they're actually techniques
people use to roll out those graphs but
I'm not going to go into that now
so we've sorted the nodes which is kind
of loosely represented here from bottom
to top
in a topological sort area sort ok so
then for the forward prop we sort of go
through the nodes and they're
topological sort order and we if it's a
variable we just said its value to what
it's very about variable value is if
it's computed from other variables their
values must have been set already
because there earlier in the topological
sort and then we compute the value of
those nodes according to their
predecessors and we pass it up and work
out the final output the loss function
of our neural network and that is our
forward pass okay so then after that we
do our backward pass and so for the
backward pass we initialize the output
gradient with one the top thing is
always one the partial of Z with respect
to Z and then we now sort of go through
the nodes in Reverse topological sort
and so therefore each of them will all
read anything that's anything that's
playing with its complex and I think
it's above it everything that we
calculated based on it in terms of
forward pass will already have had
calculated its its gradient as a product
of upstream gradient times local
gradient and then we can use that to
compute the next thing down and so
basically that what the overall role is
for any node you work out its set of
successes the things that are above it
that it that depend on it and then you
say okay the partial of Z with respect
to X is simply the sum over the set of
successes of the local gradient that you
calculate at the node times the upstream
gradient of that node and in the
examples that I gave before there was
never never multiple upstream gradients
but if you imagine a a general big graph
they could actually be sort of different
upstream gradients that are being used
in for the various successes so we apply
that backwards and then we've worked out
in back propagation the gradient of
every the gradient of the final results
Z with respect to every node in our
graph and the thing to notice about this
is if you're doing it right and
efficiently the big o order of
complexity of doing that proper
is exactly the same as doing forward
propagation eye expression evaluation so
it's not some super expensive complex
procedure that you couldn't imagine
doing and scaling up you're actually in
exactly the same complexity order okay
so as I presented here this procedure
you could just think of something that
you're running on an arbitrary graph and
calculating this forward pass and the
backwards pass I mean almost without
exception that the kind of neural nets
that we actually use have a regular
layer like structure and that's then
precisely why it makes sense to work out
these gradients in terms of vectors
matrices and jacobians as the kind we
were before okay
so since we have this sort of really
nice algorithm now this sort of means
that we can do this just computationally
and so we don't have to think or know
how to do math and we can just have our
computers do all of us with this so that
using this graph structure we can just
automatically work out how to apply
backprop and there's sort of two cases
of this right so if what was calculated
at each node is given as a symbolic
expression we could actually have our
computer work out for us what the
derivative of that symbolic expression
is so it could actually calculate the
gradient of that node and that's
referred to as often as automatic
differentiation so this is kind of like
Mathematica Wolfram Alpha if you know
how you do your math homework on it you
just type in your expression say what's
the derivative and it gives it back to
you right it's working doing symbolic
computation and working out the
derivative for you so that so that
method could be used to work out the
local gradients and then we can use the
graph structure and our rule upstream
gradient times
local gradient gives downstream gradient
ie the chain rule to then propagate it
through the graph and do the whole
backward pass completely automatically
and so that sounds great
slight disappointment current deep
learning frameworks don't quite give you
that there was actually a famous
framework that attempted to give you
that so the theano framework that was
developed at the University of Montreal
those they've now abandoned in the
modern era of large technology
corporation deep learning frameworks
Tiano did precisely that it did the full
thing of automatic differentiation for
reasons that we could either think of
good or bad current deep learning
frameworks like tensor flow or PI torch
actually do a little bit less than that
so what they do is say well for an
individual for the computations at an
individual node you have to do the
calculus for yourself for this
individual node you have to write the
forward propagation say you know return
x plus y and you have to write the
backward propagation saying the local
gradients 1 and 1/2 the 2 inputs x and y
but providing you or someone else has
written out the forward and backward
local step at this node then tensorflow
or pi torch does all the rest of it for
you and runs the back propagation
algorithm and then you know effectively
that sort of saves you having to have a
big symbolic computation engine because
somewhat the person coding the node
computations is writing a bit of code as
you might normally imagine doing it
whether in you know C or Pascal of
saying return ik x plus y and you know
local gradient return 1 right and and
you don't actually have to have a whole
symbolic computation engine okay so that
means the overall picture looks like
this right so schematically we have a
computation graph and to calculate the
for
computation we sort of put inputs into
our computation graphed where there's
sort of X and y variables and then we
run through the nodes and topologically
sorted order and for each node we
calculate its forward and necessarily
the things that depends on then have
already been computed and we just do
expression evaluation forward and then
we return the final gate in the graph
which is our loss function or objective
function but then also we have the
backward pass and for the backward pass
we go in the nodes in Reverse
topological only sorted order and for
each of those nodes we've returned their
backward value and for the top node we
return backward value of one and that
will then give us our gradients and so
that means for any node any piece of
computation that we perform we need to
write a little bit of code that says
what it's doing on the forward pass and
what it's doing on the backward pass so
on the forward pass this is our
multiplication so we're just saying
return x times y so that's pretty easy
that's what you're used to doing but
well we also need to do the backward
pass as local gradients of return what
is the partial of L with respect to Z
and with respect to X and well to do
that we have to do a little bit more
work so we have to do a little bit more
work first of all on the forward pass so
in the forward pass we have to remember
to sort of stuff away in some variables
what values we computed in the forth
with what values were given it to us in
the forward pass or else we won't be
able to calculate the backward pass so
we store away the values of x and y and
so then when we're doing the backward
pass we are passed into us the upstream
gradient the error signal and now we
just do calculate up
extreme gradient times local gradient
upstream gradient times local gradient
and we return backwards those downstream
gradients and so providing we do that
for all the nodes of our graph we then
have something that the system can run
for us as a deep learning system and so
what that means in practice is that you
know any of these deep learning
frameworks come with a whole box of
tools it says here is a fully connected
forward layer here is a sigmoid unit
here is other more complicated things
we'll do later like convolutions and
recurrent layers and to the extent that
you're using one of those somebody else
has done this work for you right that
they've defined nodes or a layer of
nodes that have forward and backward
already written foot for them and to the
extent that that's true that means that
making neural nets is heaps of farmers
just like Lego right you just stick
these layers together and say got it on
some data and train it you know it's so
easy that my high school student is
building these things right you don't
have to understand much really but you
know to the extent that you actually
want to do some original research and
think I've got this really cool idea of
how to do things differently I'm going
to define my own kind of different
computation well then you have to do
this and define your class and as well
as sort of saying how to compute the
forward value you have to pull out your
copy of Wolfram Alpha and work out what
the derivatives are and put that into
the backward pass yeah okay
so here's just one little more note on
that you know in the early days of deep
learning say prior to 2014 what we
always just to say to everybody very
sternly is you should check all your
gradients by doing numeric gradient
checks it's really really important and
so what that meant was well you know if
you want to know whether you've coded
your backward pass right an easy way to
check whether you've coded it right is
to do
this numeric gradient where you're sort
of estimating the slope by wiggling it a
bit and wiggling the input a bit and
seeing what effect it has so I'm working
out the value of the function that f of
X plus h for H very small like e to the
minus 4 and an f of X minus H and then
dividing by 2h and I'm saying well what
is the slope at this point and I'm
getting a numerical estimate of the
gradient with respect to my variable X
here now so this is what you will have
seen in high school when you did the
sort of first estimates of gradients
where you sort of worked out f of X plus
h divided by H and you're doing rise
over run and got a point estimate of the
gradient exactly the same thing except
for the fact in this case rather than
doing it one-sided like that we're doing
it two-sided it turns out that if you
actually want to do this two-sided is
asymptotically hugely better and so
you're always better off doing two-sided
gradient checks rather than one side of
gradient checks so since you saw that
since it's hard to implement this wrong
this is a good way to check that your
gradients are correct if you've defined
them yourselves as a technique to use it
for anything it's completely completely
hopeless because we're thinking of doing
this over our deep learning model for a
fully connected layer what this means is
that if you've got this sort of like a W
matrix of N by M and you want to
calculate your partial derivatives to
check if they're correct it means that
you have to do this for every element of
the matrix so you have to calculate the
eventual loss first jiggling w11 then
jiggling w12 then jiggling 1 w 1 3 1 4
etc so you have in the complex network
you'll end up literally doing millions
of function evaluations to check the
gradients at one point in time so you
know it's it's not like what I
advertised for back prop when I said
it's just as efficient as calculating
the forward value doing this is forward
value computation time x number of
parameters in our model which is often
huge for deep learning networks so this
is something that you only want to have
in side if statements that you could
turn off so you could just so run it to
check that your code isn't brick
I am D buggy you know in honesty this is
just much less needed now because you
know by and large you can plug together
your components and layers and PI torch
and other people wrote the code right
and it will work so you probably don't
need to do this all the time but it is
still a useful thing to look at to know
about if things are going wrong yeah
okay so if we've now mastered the core
technology of neural nets we saw know
basically everything we need to know
about neural nets and I sort of just
summarized it there just to sort of
emphasize once more you know I think
some people think why do we even need to
learn all this stuff about gradients and
there's a sense in which so don't really
because these modern deep learning
frameworks will compute all the
gradients for you you know we make you
suffer in homework 2 but in homework 3
you can have your gradients and computed
for you but you know I so you know it's
sort of just like well why should you
take a class on compilers right that
there's actually something useful in
understanding what goes on under the
hood even though most of the time we're
just perfectly happy to let the C
compiler do its thing
without being experts on x86 assembler
every day of the world week but you know
there is more to it than that
you know because even though back
propagation is great once you're
building complex models back propagation
doesn't always work as you would expect
it to perfectly it may be the wrong word
because you know mathematically it's
perfect but it might not be achieving
what you're wanting it to and well if
you want to sort of in debug and improve
models it's kind of crucial to
understand what's going on there's a
nice medium
by Andre Kapaa fee of yes you should
understand backdrop but on the syllabus
page that talks about this and indeed
week after next
Abby is actually going to lecture about
recurrent neural networks and you know
one of the places where you can easily
fail and doing that propagation turns up
there it's a good example ok does anyone
have any questions about back
propagation and computation graphs okay
if not the remainder of the time is the
grab bag of things that you really
should know about if you're going to be
doing deep learning and so yeah this is
just itsy-bitsy and but let me say them
so up until now when we've had loss
functions and we've been maximizing the
likelihood of our data and stuff like
that we've sort of just had this part
here which is the likelihood of our data
and we've worked to maximize it however
in practice that works badly usually and
we need to do something else which is
regularize our models and if you've done
the machine learning class or something
like that you will have seen
regularization and there are various
techniques to do regularization but
compared to anything else regularization
is even more important for deep learning
models right so the general idea is if
you have a lot of parameters in your
model those parameters can just
essentially memorize what's in the data
that you trained it and so they're very
good at predicting the answers the model
becomes very good at predicting their
answers to the data you trained it on
but the model may become poor at working
in the real world and different examples
and somehow we want to stop that and
this problem is especially bad for deep
learning models because typically deep
learning models have
vast numbers of parameters so in the
good old days when statisticians ruled
the show they told people that it was
completely ridiculous to have a number
of parameters that approached your
number of training examples you know you
should never have more parameters in
your model than one-tenth of the number
of your training examples from what's
the kind of rules of thumb you are told
so that you had lots of examples with
which Westar made every parameter that's
just not true deep learning models it's
just really common that we train deep
learning models that have ten times as
many parameters as there we have
training examples but miraculously it
works in fact it works brilliantly those
highly over parameterised models and
it's one of the big secret sources of my
deep learning has been so brilliant but
it only works if we regularize the model
so if you train a model without
sufficient regularization what you find
is that your training it and working out
your loss on the training data and the
model keeps on getting better and better
and better and better
necessarily our algorithm has to improve
loss on the training data so the worst
thing that could happen is that the
graph could become absolutely fat flat
what you will find is with most models
that we train they have so many
parameters that this will just keep on
going down until the loss is sort of
approaching the numerical precision of
zero if you leave a training for long
enough it just learns the correct answer
that every example because because
effectively can memorize examples okay
but if you then say let me test out this
model on some different data what you
find is this red curve that up until a
certain point that you're also building
a model that's better at predicting on
different data but after some point this
curve starts to curve up again and
ignore that bit where it seems to curve
down again that was a mistake in the
drawing and so this has then referred to
as overfitting that them from here on
the training model was just learning to
memorize whatever was in
the training data but not in a way that
lets it generalize to other examples and
so this is not what we want we want to
try and avoid overfitting as much as
possible and there are various
regularization techniques that we use
for that and a simple starting one is
this one here where we penalize the
log-likelihood by saying you're going to
be penalized to the extent that you move
parameters away from zero so the default
state of nature is all parameters are
zero so they're ignored in computations
you can have parameters that have big
values but you'll be penalized a bit for
and this is referred to as l2
regularization and you know that's sort
of a starting point of something
sensible you could do with
regularization
but there's more to say later and we'll
talk in the sort of lecture before we
discuss final projects of other clever
and regularization techniques and neural
networks ok grab bag number two
vectorization is the term that you hear
but it's not only vectors this is also
matrix ization and higher dimensional
matrices what are called tensors in this
field tensor ization getting deep
learning systems to run fast and
efficiently is only possible if we
vectorize things and what does that mean
what that means is you know the
straightforward way to write a lot of
code that you saw in your first CS class
is you say for I in range in calculate
random Randi 1 but when we want to be
clever people that are doing things fast
we say rather than work out this w dot
one-word vector at a time and do it in a
for loop we could instead put all of our
word vectors into one matrix and then do
simply one matrix matrix multiply of W
by our word vector matrix
and even if you run your code on your
laptop on the CPU you will find out that
if you do it
the vectorized way things will become
hugely faster so in this example it
became over an order of magnitude faster
when doing it with a vector vectorized
rather than with a for loop and those
gains are only compounded when we run
code on a GPU that you will get no gains
and speed at all on a GPU unless your
code is vectorized but if it is
vectorized then you can hope to have
results of how oh yeah this runs 40
times faster than it did on the CPU okay
yeah so always try to use vectors and
matrices not for loops of course it's
useful when developing stuff to time
your code and find out what's slow okay
point three okay so we discussed this
idea last time and the time before that
after after having the sort of a fine
layer where we took you know go from X
to W X plus B that's referred to as an
affine layer so we're doing this
multiplying a vector by matrix matrix
and adding biases we necessarily to have
power in a deep network have to have
some form of non-linearity
and so I just wanted to go through a bit
of background on non-linearity isn't
what people use and what to use so if
you're sort of starting from the idea of
what we know as logistic regression
what's commonly referred to as the
sigmoid curve or maybe more precisely
look the logistic function is this
picture here so it's something that
squashes any real number positive or
negative into the range zero to one it
gives you a probability output these
this use of this logistic function was
really really common in early neural
nets if you go back to 80s 90s neural
Nets
there were sigmoid functions absolutely
everywhere in more recent times 90% of
the time nobody uses these and they've
been found to sort of actually work
quite poorly the only place these are
used is when you actually want a value
between 0 & 1 as your output so we'll
talk later about how you have gating in
networks and so gating as a place where
you want to have a probability between
two things and then you will use one of
those but you use them absolutely
nowhere else here is the 10 H curve so
the formula for 10h looks like a scary
thing with lots of Exponential's in it
and it doesn't really look much like a
logistic curve whatsoever but if you dig
up your math textbook you can convince
yourself that a 10h curve is actually
exactly the same as the logistic curve
apart from you multiply it by two so it
has a range of two rather than one and
you shift it down one so this is sort of
just a rescaled logistic but it's now
symmetric between 1 and -1 and the fact
it's symmetric in the output actually
helps a lot for putting into neural
networks so teenagers are still
reasonably widely used and quite a
number of places in neural networks so
10h should be a friend of yours and you
should know about that but you know one
of the bad things about using
transcendental functions like the
sigmoid or 10h is you know they involve
this expensive math operations that slow
you down like it's sort of a nuisance to
be kind of computing Exponential's and
ten HS and new computer things are kind
of slow so people started playing around
with ways of to make things faster and
so someone came up with this idea like
maybe we could come up with a hard 10 H
where it's just sort of flat out here
and then it has a linear slope and then
it's flat at the top you know it sort of
looks like a 10 H but we've just squared
it off and well this is really cheap to
compute right you say
less than -1 return -1 return +1 or just
return the number no complex
transcendentals the funny thing is it
turns out that this actually works
pretty well you might be scared and you
might justify ibly b squared because if
you start thinking about gradients once
you're over here there's no gradient
right it's tube completely flat at 0 so
things go dead as soon as they're out at
one of the ends so it's sort of
important to stay in this middle section
at least for a while and then it's just
got a slope of 1 right it's a constant
slope of 1 but this is enough of a
linearity that actually it works well in
neural networks and you can train neural
networks so that sent the whole field in
the opposite direction and people
thought oh if that works maybe we can
make things even simpler and that led to
the now-famous what's referred to
everywhere as a reloj sorry I miss
there's a mistake in my editing there
delete off hard 10 H that was in the
slides by mistake the r-la unit everyone
calls it reloj which stands for
rectified linear unit so the the reloj
is essentially the simplest
non-linearity you can have so the relu
is zero slope zero as soon as you're in
the negative regime and it's just a line
slope one when you're in the positive
regime I mean when I first saw this I
mean it sort of blew my mind it could
possibly work because it's sort of I
guess I was brought up on these sort of
10 HS and sigmoids and there's sort of
these arguments about the slope and you
get these gradients and you can move
around with the gradient and how is it
meant to work if half of this function
just has output zero and no gradient and
the other half is just this straight
line and in particular when you're in
the positive regime this is just an
identity function and you know I sort of
argued before that if you've just
compose
linear transforms you don't get any
power but providing we're in these the
right-hand part of the regime since this
is an identity function that's exactly
what we're doing we're just composing
linear transforms so you sort of believe
it just couldn't possibly work but it
turns out that this works brilliantly
and this is now by far the default
choice when people are building feed for
deep networks that people use really
nonlinearities and they are very fast
they train very quickly and they perform
very well and so effectively you know
the it is it is simply just each you
depending on the inputs each unit is
just either dead or it's passing things
on as an identity function but there's
enough of a linear non-linearity that
you can do arbitrary function
approximation still with a deep learning
network and people now make precisely
the opposite argument which is because
this unit just has a slope of 1 over
it's nonzero range that means the
gradient is passed back very efficiently
to the inputs and therefore them the
models train very efficiently whereas
when you were with these kind of curves
when you're over here there's very
little slope so your models might train
very slowly ok so you know for
feed-forward network try this before you
try anything else but there's sort of
them being a sub literature that says
well maybe that's too simple and we
could do a bit better and so that led to
the leaky reloj which said maybe we
should put a tiny bit of slope over here
so it's not completely dead so you can
make it something like 1 1/100 as the
slope is this part and then people had
well let's build off that maybe we could
actually put another parameter into our
neural network and we could have a
parametric reloj so there's some slope
over here but we're also going to back
propagate into our non-linearity which
has this extra alpha parameter which is
how many much
and so variously people have used these
you can sort of find tin papers on
archive where people say you can get
better results from using one or other
of these you can also find papers where
people say it made no difference for
them versus just using a reloj so I
think basically you can start off with a
reloj and work from there yeah so
parameter initialization it's when so
when we have these matrices of
parameters in our model it's vital vital
vital that you have to initialize those
parameter weights with small random
values this was precisely the lesson
that some people hadn't discovered when
it came to final project time so I'll
emphasize it vital vital so if you just
start off with the weights being zero
you kind of have these complete
symmetries right that everything will be
calculated the same everything will move
the same and you're not actually
training this complex network with a lot
of Units that are specializing to learn
different things so somehow you have to
break the symmetry and we do that by
giving small random weights so you know
there's sort of some fine points when
you have biases you may as well just
start them at zero as neutral and see
how the system learn the bias that you
want et cetera but in general the
weights you want to initialize the small
random values you'll find in height or
other deep learning practice packages a
common initialization that's used and
often recommended as this Xavier
initialization and so the trick of this
is that for a lot of models in a lot of
places think of some of these things
like these ones and these you'd like the
values in the network to sort of stay
small in this sort of middle range here
and well if you kind of have a matrix
with big values in it and you multiply
vector by this matrix you know things
might get bigger and then if you put in
through another layer
get bigger again and then sort of
everything I'll be too big and you'll
have problems so really Xavier
initializations seeking to avoid that by
saying how many inputs are there to this
node how many outputs are there we want
to sort of tamp it down the
initialization based on the inputs and
the outputs because effectively we'll be
using this number that many times it's a
good thing to use you can use that
optimizers
up till now we saw just talked about
plain SGD you know normally plain SGD
actually works just fine but often if
you want to use just plain SGD you have
to spend time tuning the learning rate
that alpha that we multiplied the
gradient by for complex nets and
situations or to avoid worry there's
sort of now this big family and more
sophisticated adaptive optimizers and so
effectively they're scaling the
parameter adjustment by accumulated
gradients which have the effect that
they learn per parameter learning rate
so that they conceived which parameters
would be useful to move more and which
ones less depending on the sensitivity
of those parameters so where things are
flat you can be trying to move quickly
where things are bouncing around a lot
you can be trying to move just a little
so as not to overshoot and so there's a
whole family of these a degrade rmsprop
Atom they're actually other ones there's
a de Max and a lot of them I mean Adam
is one fairly reliable one that many
people use and that's not bad and then
one more slide and I'm done yeah so
learning rates so normally you have to
choose a learning rate so one choice is
just have a constant learning rate you
pick a number maybe 10 to the minus 3
and say that's my learning rate you want
your learning rate to be order of
magnitude right if your learning rate is
too big your model might diverge or not
converge because adjusts of leaps you
around by huge cramp
movements and you completely miss the
good parts of your function space if
your model if your learning rate is too
small your model may not train by the
assignment deadline and then you'll be
unhappy so if you saw it you know
commonly people sort of try powers of
ten and sees how it looks right they
might try you know 0.0 1.0 01.00 1 and
see look at how the loss is declining
and see what seems to work in general
you want to use the fastest learning
rate that isn't making things become
unstable commonly you get better results
by decreasing the learning rate as you
train so sometimes people just do that
by hand so we used the term epoch for a
full pass through your training data and
people might say half the learning rate
after every three epochs as you train
and that can work pretty well you can
use formulas to get per epoch rate
learning rates there are even fancier
methods you can look up cyclic learning
rates online if you want which sort of
actually makes the learning rate
sometimes bigger and then sometimes
smaller and people have found that that
can be useful for getting you out of bad
regions and interesting ways the one
other thing to know is if you're using
one of the fancier optimizers they still
ask you for a learning rate but that
learning rate is the initial learning
rate which typically the optimizer will
shrink as you train so commonly if
you're using something like atom you
might be starting off by saying the
learning raises zero point one sort of a
bigger number and it'll be shrinking it
later as the training goes along ok all
done see you next week